foreign
one who's been paying attention for the
last few months has been seeing
headlines like this especially in
education the thesis has been students
are going to be using chat GPT and other
forms of AI to cheat do their
assignments they're not going to learn
and it's going to completely undermine
education as we know it
now what I'm going to argue today is not
only are there ways to mitigate all of
that if we put the right guard rails we
do the right things we can mitigate it
but I think we're at the cost of using
AI for probably the biggest
trans-positive transformation that
education has ever seen and the way
we're going to do that is by giving
every student on the planet an
artificially intelligent but amazing
personal tutor and we're going to give
every teacher on the planet a an amazing
artificially intelligent teaching
assistant
and just to appreciate how big of a deal
it would be to give everyone a personal
tutor I show you this clip from Benjamin
Bloom's 1984 to Sigma study where he
called it the two Sigma problem the two
Sigma comes from two standard deviation
Sigma the symbol for standard deviation
and he had good data that showed that
look a normal distribution that's the
one that you see in the the traditional
bell curve right in the middle that's
how you know the world kind of sorts
itself out
that if you were to give personal one to
one to tutoring for students that you
can actually get a distribution that
looks like that right it says tutorial
one to one with the asterisk like that
right distribution a two standard
deviation Improvement just to put that
in plain language that could take your
average student and turn them into an
exceptional student it can take your
below average student and turn them into
an above average student
now the reason why he framed it as a
problem was he said well this is all
good but how do you actually scale group
instruction this way how do you actually
give it to everyone in an economic way
what I'm about to show you is I think
the first moves towards doing that
obviously we've been trying to
approximate it in some way at Khan
Academy for over a decade now but I
think we're at the cusp of accelerating
it dramatically I'm going to show you
the early stages of what Rai which we
call conmigo
what it can now do and maybe a little
bit of where it is actually going
so this right over here is a traditional
exercise that you or many of your
children might have seen on Khan Academy
but what's new is uh that little little
bot thing at the right and we'll start
by seeing one of the very important
safeguards which is the conversation is
recorded and viewable by your teacher
it's moderated actually by a second Ai
and also it does not tell you the answer
it is not a cheating tool notice when
the student says tell me the answer it
says I'm your tutor what do you think is
the next step for solving the problem
now if the student makes a mistake and
this will surprise people who think
large language models are not good at
mathematics
notice not only does it notice the
mistake it asks the student to explain
their reasoning but it's actually doing
what I would say not just even an
average tutor would do but an excellent
tutor would do it's actually it's able
to Divine what is probably the
misconception in that student's mind
that they probably didn't Use the
distributive property remember we need
to distribute the negative 2 to both the
9 and the 2m inside of the parentheses
this to me is a very very very big deal
and it's not just in math
this is a computer programming exercise
on Khan Academy where the student needs
to make the clouds part
and so we can see the student starts
defining a variable left x minus minus
it only made the left Cloud part but
then they can ask a conmigo what's going
on why is only the left Cloud moving and
it understands the code it knows all the
context of what the student is doing and
it understands that those ellipses are
there to draw clouds which I think is
kind of mind-blowing and it says to make
the right Cloud boot as well try adding
a line of code inside the draw function
that increments the right X variable by
one pixel in each frame
now this this one is maybe even more
amazing because we have a lot of math
teachers we've all been trying to Teach
the World to code but there aren't a lot
of computing teachers out there and what
you just saw even when I'm tutoring my
kids when they're learning to code I
can't help them this well this fast this
is really going to be a super tutor
and it's not just exercises it
understands what you're watching it
understands the context of your video it
can answer the age-old question why do I
need to learn this and it asks
socratically well what do you care about
and let's say the student says I want to
be a professional athlete and it says
well learning about the size of cells
which is what this video is on that
could be really useful for Understanding
Nutrition and how your body works Etc it
can answer questions it can quiz you it
can connect it to other ideas you can
now ask as many questions of a video as
you could ever dream of
so
another big shortage out there I
remember the high school I went to the
student to guidance counselor ratio was
about 200 or 300 to 1. a lot of the
country it's worse than that
we can use conmigo to give every student
a guidance counselor academic coach
career coach life coach which is exactly
what you see right over here and this is
all you know we launched this with the
gpt4 launch we have a few thousand
people on this this isn't a fake demo
this is this is really it in in action
and then there's you know things that I
think it would have been even harder it
would have been a little science fiction
to do with even a traditional tutor
there's a student we run an online high
school with Arizona State University
called Khan World school and we have a
student who attends that online school
at Basin India her name sanvi and she
was doing a report on The Great Gatsby
and when she was reading The Great
Gatsby Jay Gatsby keeps looking at the
green light off into the distance and
she's like well why does he do that she
did some web searches and people have
obviously studied this and commented
about the symbolism of that but none of
it was really resonating with her and
then she realized that she had conmigo
and that she could talk to Jay Gatsby
himself
and so ah Splendid Choice Soul sport I
am now Jay Gatsby the enigmatic
millionaire from F Scott Gerald's
classic and so why do you keep staring
at the green light ah the green light
old sport it's a symbol of my dreams and
desires you see it's situated at the end
of Daisy Buchanan's dock across the bay
from my Mansion I gazed at it longingly
as it represents my yearning for the
past and my hope to reunite with Daisy
the love of my life
and what was cool is Sandy had said I
had this long conversation she called
him Mr Gatsby and at the end she
actually apologized for taking his time
which I thought was very polite of her
but you can imagine this unlocks
learning literature learning uh you
could talk to historical figures we're
even probably going to add an activity
you can talk to like the Mississippi
River it brings things to life in ways
that you would that really were science
fiction even six months or or a year ago
students can get into debates with the
AI and we've got the series of students
debating whether we should cancel
student debt the student is against
counseling student debt and we've gotten
very clear feedback we started running
it at Conroe School in our lab school
that we have con lab school the students
the high school students especially
they're saying this is amazing to be
able to fine-tune my arguments without
fearing judgment it makes me that much
more confident to kind of go into the
classroom and really participate and we
all know that Socratic dialogue debate
is one a great way to learn but frankly
it's not out there for most students but
now it can be accessible to hopefully
everyone
a lot of the narrative we saw that in
the headlines has been it's going to do
the writing for kids kids are not going
to learn to write but we are showing
that there's ways that the AI doesn't
write for you it writes with you so this
is a little thing and my eight-year-old
is addicted to this and he's not a kid
that really liked writing before but
where uh you know you could say I want
to write a horror story and it says ooh
a Horror Story how spine tingling and
thrilling let's dive into the world of
eerie shadows and chilling Mysteries and
this is an activity where the student
will write two sentences and then the AI
will write two sentences and so they
collaborate together on a story the
students right Beatrice was a
misunderstood ghost she wanted to make
friends but kept scaring them by
accident and the AI says poor Beatrice a
lonely Spirit yearning for companionship
one day she stumbled upon an old
abandoned mansion etc etc I encourage
you all to you know hopefully one day
try this this is surprisingly fun
now to even more directly hit this use
case and what I'm about to show you
everything I showed you so far is
actually all part already part of kaniga
what I'm about to show you we haven't
shown to anyone yet this is a prototype
we hope to be able to launch it in the
next few months but this is to directly
use AI use generative AI to not
undermine English and language arts but
to actually enhance it in ways that we
couldn't have even conceived of even a
year ago this is reading comprehension
the students reading Steve Jobs famous
speech at Stanford and then as they get
to certain points they can click on that
little question
and the AI will then socratically almost
like an oral exam ask the student about
things and the AI can highlight parts of
the passage why did the author use that
word what was their intent does it back
up their argument they can start to do
stuff that once again we never had the
the capability to give everyone a tutor
everyone a writing coach to actually dig
into reading at this level
and you could go on the other side of it
we have a whole workflows it helps them
right helps them be a right a writing
coach draw an outline but once a student
actually constructs a draft and this is
where they're constructing a draft they
can ask for feedback once again as you
would expect from a good writing coach
in this case the student will say let's
say it does by evidence support my claim
and then the AI not only is able to get
feedback but it's able to highlight
certain parts of the past and says you
know In this passage this doesn't quite
support your claim but once again
socratically says can you tell us why so
it's pulling the student it's making
them a better writer giving them far
more feedback than they've ever been
able to to actually get before and we
think this is going to dramatically
accelerate writing not hurt it
now everything I've talked about so far
is for the student but we think this
could be equally as powerful for the
teacher to drive more personalized
education and frankly save time and
energy for themselves and for their
students so this is an American history
exercise on Khan Academy it's a question
about the Spanish-American or sorry the
uh Spanish-American war and
um at first it's in student mode and if
you say tell me the answer it's not
going to tell the answer it's going to
go into tutoring mode but that little
toggle which teachers have access to
they can turn student mode off and then
it goes into teacher mode and what this
does is it turns into you could view it
as a teacher's guide on steroids not
only can It explain the answer it can
explain how you might want to teach it
it can help prepare the Stu the teacher
for that material it can help them
create lesson plans as you could see
doing right there it'll eventually help
them create progress reports and help
them eventually grade so once again
teachers spend about half their time
with this type of activity lesson
planning all of that energy can go back
to them or go back to human interactions
with their actual students
so
you know one point I want to make these
large language models are so powerful
there's a temptation to say like well
all these people are just going to slap
them onto their websites and it kind of
turns the applications themselves into
into Commodities and what I got to tell
you is I kind of thought that that's one
of the reasons why I didn't sleep for
two weeks when I when I first had access
to uh gpt4 back in August
but we quickly realized that to actually
make it magical I think what you saw
with conmigo a little bit it didn't
interact with you the way that you see
chat GPT interacting it was a little bit
more magical it was more Socratic it was
clearly much better at math than what
most people are used to to thinking and
the reason is there was a lot of work
behind the scenes to make that happen
and I could go through the whole list of
everything we've been working on many
many people for over six seven months to
make it feel magical but what perhaps
the most intellectually interesting one
is we realized that this was an idea
from an open AI researcher that we could
dramatically improve its ability in math
and its ability in tutoring if we
allowed the AI to think before it speaks
so if you're tutoring someone and you
immediately just start talking before
you assess their math you might not get
it right but if you construct thoughts
for yourself and what you see on the
right there is an actual AI thought
something that it generates for itself
but it does not share with the student
then it's accuracy went up dramatically
and its ability to be a world-class
tutor went up dramatically and you can
see it's still talking to itself here it
says the student got a different answer
than I did but do not tell them they
made a mistake instead ask them to play
explain how they got to that that step
so I'll just finish off hopefully you
know what I've just shown you is just
half of what we are working on and we
think is this is just the very tip of
the iceberg of where this this can
actually go and I'm pretty convinced
which I wouldn't have been even a year
ago that we together have a chance of
addressing the two Sigma problem and
turning it into a two Sigma opportunity
dramatically accelerating
education as as we know it
now just to take a step back at a metal
level obviously we heard a lot today the
debates on either side there's folks who
take a more pessimistic view of AI they
say this is scary there's all these
dystopian scenarios we maybe want to
slow down we want to pause on the other
side there are the more optimistic folks
to say well we've gone through
inflection points before we've gone
through the Industrial Revolution it was
scary but it all kind of worked out
and what I'd argue right now is I don't
think this is like a flip of a coin or
this is something where we'll just have
to like wait and see which way it turns
out I think everyone here and Beyond we
are active participants in this decision
I'm pretty convinced that the first line
of reasoning is actually almost a
self-fulfilling prophecy that if we act
with fear and if we say hey we just got
to stop doing this stuff
what's really going to happen is the
rule followers might pause might slow
down but the rule Breakers as Alexander
mentioned the totalitarian governments
the criminal organizations they're only
going to accelerate and that leads to
what I am pretty convinced is the
dystopian state which is the good actors
have worse AIS than the Bad actors
but I'll also you know talk to The
Optimist a little bit I don't think that
means that oh yeah then we should just
relax and just hope for the best
that might not happen either I think all
of us together have to fight like hell
to make sure that we put the guard rails
we put in when it when the problems
arise reasonable regulations but we
fight like hell for the positive use
cases because very close to my heart and
obviously there's many potential
positive use cases but perhaps the most
powerful use case and a perhaps the most
poetic use case is if AI artificial
intelligence can be used to enhance hi
human intelligence human potential and
human purpose
thank you